these are all for the golden jubilee
and the recipe mentions the main
qualities for a perfect queen it's funny
the things she's been sent over the
years that's very fun business
i could encourage a lot of hard work and
a dash of loyalty a recipe for the
perfect queen just one of the items
stashed away from past jubilees so
they've all been kept
somewhere
they will all be preserved in the
archives
as this weekend she prepares for the
beginning of her platinum jubilee year
simple but ingenious which includes a
competition to find a new pudding
i've also got we've had a number of
platinum pudding competition entries
that have been coming in in recent weeks
so people are being very creative
there's all the ingredients oh i see the
intro yes the number of recipes
for the queen the start of any jubilee
year always comes with mixed feelings
sunday will mark 70 years since her
father died a king who had indeed spent
his strength in the selfless service of
his people
seven decades since she became queen
marking the start of an extraordinary
reign
her platinum jubilee will be a first for
any british monarch a milestone not even
queen victoria managed this fan from
victoria's golden jubilee certainly
seemed to catch her attention in some
ways a rare royal autograph book signed
by victoria's extended family including
the future monarchs king edward vii and
tsar nicholas ii of russia and it's
still shut
yes it was beautiful
oh good
well that's very interesting to see this
summer we will again see big
celebrations
[Music]
for now someone else needs the queen's
attention i know what you want
rhiannon mills sky news